lexie poulain cofondateur du monde
moderne dont soit alexis poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct pour
commenter c'est différents événements de
la journée 9e groupe à l'assemblée le
parti présidentiel qui perd sa majorité
c'est un symbole fort c'est de cela on
parle aujourd'hui si un symbole c'est
dans les neuf groupes c'est le fait que
la cinquième arrive vraiment à sa fin et
que peut-être qu'on est mûr pour un
régime parlementaire où le pouvoir se
ferait là où on fabrique les lois à
l'assemblée nationale et où un seul
homme cloîtré dans un palais celui de
l'elysée ne déciderait pas de tous pour
la destinée de plus de 60 millions de
français donc c'est une bonne chose oui
on ne peut que s'en réjouir de voir que
certains députés décident de créer un
nouveau groupe
maintenant ne soyons pas dupes il s'agit
de députés marcheurs ils sortent du lot
parce que moi j'y vois là via un
rassemblement d'ambitieux qui font
monter leur cote de ministrables qui
sortent de la cohorte des députés
playmobil de députés godillots comme on
appelle les députés marcheurs qui vont
se faire remarquer qu'ils vont avoir une
existence propre qui vont aussi et bien
c'est pouvoir montrer ce qu'ils valent
ou bien comment en force de nos
positions parce que elle est fictive il
ne quitte pas la majorité
attendons de voir s'il montre une
voteront une motion de censure contre un
prochain gouvernement
rien n'est moins sûr et puis là encore
il était d'accord pendant toutes ces
années avec emmanuel macron est en
marche je ne vois pas pourquoi du jour
au lendemain ils changeraient est le mot
d'ordre est simple il s'agit à mon avis
de sauver le soldat maquereau en
montrant que oui à en marche il y a
aussi un peu de gauche et que ces gens
là vont faire un futur gouvernement pour
finir le quinquennat un peu plus social
un peu plus écologiste comme on aimerait
le voir
j'y vois plutôt une manoeuvre assez
habile de la part de ses députés
sécessionniste mais pas plus donc ça
veut dire que la comparaison je
reconnais que je la fais souvent parce
que ça me rappelle tout simplement cette
époque là les frondeurs de l'ale gauche
a du président hollande qu'il n'y avait
pas forcément porté chance on s'en
souvient cette comparaison la n'a pas
d'être pour vous en l'espèce je ne pense
pas dans la mesure où là on a affaire
déjà d'être député qui crée un groupe et
la feuille de route dans marche dès le
début c'était mounir mahjoubi qui en
parlait il fallait que en marche
organise et le tout le débat c'est à
dire qu'il fera l'opposition qu'il soit
la majorité
et là on est dans des romans de ce plan
c'est à dire que en marche n'ayant pas
réussi à organiser le débat est bien là
il s'organise avec ce groupe de
frondeurs comme si vous souhaitez les
appeler mais je ne vois pas des fondeurs
j'y vois une mise en scène politique
pour sauver le soldat aimerait de mâcon
parce que c'est des proches du premier
cercle qui vont rejoindre ce groupe
donc on sait très bien que là ils vont
pas aller à l'encontre de celui qui les
a faits et une lui doivent tout et en
l'occurrence ils vont pas aller à
l'encontre de cette politique c'est
plutôt préparé 2022
avec ce groupe qui va aller draguer du
côté de la gauche pour éviter qu'un pôle
de gauche écologistes ne voit le jour un
vrai celui-là on crée beaucoup plus à
gauche beaucoup plus conscients de
l'importance de la justice sociale de
l'égalité et mâcon c'est le président
des riches
malgré tout ce qu'il a essayé de dire de
faire il reste celui qui a supprimé les
sf qui a fait exploser les inégalités
dans ce pays qui a cassé le droit social
le droit du travail déjà sous françois
hollande il ne changera pas il ne va pas
changer donc ceux-là sont là pour
l'aider à faire croire qu'il ya encore
un peu de gauche
si j'ai ce président de droite dure de
droite néolibérale classique jeu je ne
vois pas comment ça pourrait prendre
avec vont accompagner ce président qui
dit vouloir se réinventer le président
de weave l'après crise qu'ovide 19
ça fait partie de la réinvention des
malades seront évidemment et vous verrez
que nombreux de ses députés vont
rejoindre sans doute un prochain
gouvernement d'union nationale entre
guillemets ils sont là pour aider manama
kron à gauchy à verdir son image
c'est un manoeuvre c'est un coup de
peinture sur une maison qui s'effondre
c'est l'art m c'était une promesse un ni
de droite ni de gauche
ça voulait dire complètement de droite
mais de celle d'emmanuel mâcon qui n'est
même pas la droite gaulliste il a bien
du mal à se mettre dans les habits du
général de gaulle ou même de faire une
droite sociale
comme elle a pu exister donc c'est
vraiment une manoeuvre pour préparer
2022 montrer à ceux qui sont encore
sensibles aux sirènes du maquereau nisme
que celui ci est bien il est encore
progressiste parce qu'on a du mal à voir
le progrès dans les yeux arrachés les
mains arrachées la violence qu'il ya eu
ces dernières ces derniers mois moi
j'appelle emmanuel macron le président
de la violence parce qu'il n'a jamais
condamné ouvertement la façon dont les
manifestants ont été traitées sous son
quinquennat
mais la violence sociale également la
casse rapide avec laquelle il a voulu
mettre à la poubelle le système de
retraite français en disant qu'il
fallait davantage et bien de répartition
et autres et fait rentrer les fonds de
tensions dans un système qui
fonctionnait je ne vois pas comment tout
ça pourrait changer à part comme ça a
été le cas sous nicolas sarkozy par de
beaux discours
en réalité ce sont des mots il faut voir
les faits et les faits ils sont têtus
autre événement de la journée
l'hypothèse de ce second tour qui re
surgir pour le mois de juin après le feu
on va dire orange du conseil
scientifique c'est une bonne chose pour
vous fin juin pour moi n'ont rien
maintenant qu'ils la souhaitent en tout
cas ceux qui ont été en valeur taja
favorable c'est ça pour tout ce qu'on
fait campagne
ce serait une bonne chose parce que
c'est beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'investissement beaucoup d'argent donc
il faut clore l'épisode des municipales
et puis il ya calendrier électoral à
respecter
derrière c'est les régionales et
sénatoriales et d'autres et puis 2022
donc tout le monde veut en finir avant
tout le monde tous ceux qui ont fait
campagne souhaiterait je pense en finir
avec les municipales mais dans un cadre
sanitaire sur alors ça tombe bien on a
maintenant des conseils scientifiques
qui conseille les politiques pour leur
dire que on peut y aller là on peut sans
doute faire un deuxième tour quand on
s'appelle comment est effet le premier
tour la veille du confinement évidemment
ça pose beaucoup de questions le
problème c est ce que ce premier tour
est valide pour une tenue du taux de
participation et des gens qui sont allés
voter
est-ce que ce deuxième tour s'il a lieu
fin juin sera lui aussi du même acabit
et est valide donc ces municipales elles
resteront comme les municipales du duc
au vide du coronavirus elles sont
particulières
il faut pas oublier bien sûr tous les
assesseurs les responsables de bureau
les gens qui sont ou qui ont été
touchées par ce virus certains sont
décédés
malheureusement donc n'oublions pas
quand même c'est un curry qui a été le
premier tour il faut pas que ça se
répète pour le second tour donc s'il
doit avoir lieu il faut que les
garanties soient à 100% de ne pas mettre
en danger la santé des électeurs et des
assesseurs dernier point avec six
poulains la plus haute juridiction
administrative 1 le conseil d'état
estimé dans une ordonnance que
l'interdiction a voulu par le
gouvernement portent atteinte grave et
manifestement illégale à la liberté de
culte
ces rassemblements donc dans les
endroits de deux cuts et un camouflé
aujourd'hui pour le gouvernement on peut
le prendre comme ça de la part de la
plus haute juridiction
c'est pas le seul oui et heureusement il
ya eu aussi cette interdiction des
drones policier qui était une atteinte
au droit à la vie privée
tant mieux et nous vivons bien en
démocratie nous vivons bien dans un état
de droit malgré les coups de maillet qui
sont fait à nos droits à cause de ce
régime d'exception
il est heureux que des institutions
veille que des contre-pouvoirs existent
pour éviter que notre démocratie
libérale rentrer dans un régime libéral
tout ça sous prétexte de sécurité et de
et de faire attention à la santé des
français
il n'en est rien donc tant mieux plus on
peut défendre les libertés
mieux c'est et croyez moi c'est jamais
en limitant les libertés qu'on gagne en
sécurité
merci beaucoup alexis poulard d'avoir
été avec nous pour analyser c'est point
politique de la journée merci à vous